I'm a little bit too old for
speed-dating so when Steve invited me to
give a speed lecture I decided to agree
so as not to miss the next great new
thing so diving right into the topic of
interest the first law of thermodynamics
as you know says that energy can neither
be created nor destroyed when apply to
living systems we have the familiar
equation calorie intake
- expenditure equals calories stored or
in humans change in body fat since most
of our calories are stored in an adipose
tissue according to the conventional
interpretation of this law
obesity represents the voluntary failure
over energy balance in other words in an
environment with ubiquitous tasty foods
we easily over consumed without enough
opportunities for physical activity we
don't burn off those calories the excess
metabolic fuels rich calorie rich fuels
build up in the bloodstream glucose
fatty acids and light and are forced
into fat cells causing these fat cells
to become anabolic and expand so from
this perspective the simple solution is
just to eat less and move more
unfortunately things haven't worked out
so well according to Ann Haynes
nationally representative survey only 1
in 6 overweight or obese adults report
ever having lost 10% of their body
weight for just one year and that's
likely this depressing result is likely
to be overestimated because we all think
we're a little taller and a little
thinner than we actually are
in fact we know that standard treatments
for obesity have been an abject failure
and we have to ask why why such a simple
paradigm just eat less and move more has
failed
well according to another view which
also adheres to the laws of
thermodynamics we've had the arrows of
causality in the wrong direction they
don't move from right to left
they move from left to right so this
view places the focus on the adipocyte
according to this model something has
triggered fat cells to become anabolic
and suck up too many calories
and so the bloodstream has too few not
too many calories and that's perceived
as an energy crisis by the brain which
drives us to get hungry and eat more to
replace those missing calories in the
blood and also lower energy expenditure
to conserve and what has triggered fat
cells to become anabolic potentially
many things but the most likely culprit
is high insulin levels insulin is the
ultimate anabolic hormone and what is
driving insulin secretion
that's endocrinology 101 refined
carbohydrates so to look at this
possibility within this study I'll just
show you briefly three studies this was
with twelve obese adolescents studied in
a crossover fashion with three meals
either instant oatmeal highly processed
old fashioned or steel-cut oats same
amount of carbohydrate but minimally
processed or a vegetable omelet with
fruit no processed carbohydrate at all
and so we saw after the subjects ate
these foods that blood sugar rose the
highest after the instant oatmeal after
compared to the other two and insulin
rose I'm not showing you insulin also
rose higher but then blood sugar came
down into a relatively hypoglycemic
range under the influence of all the
insulin secreted this was a
statistically significant comparison and
at that time epinephrine or adrenaline
that's an emergency stress hormone
secreted at very high level same
calories but very different metabolic
states later and when we gave subjects
free access to food they can consumed
seven or eight hundred calories more
after the high glycemic index rapidly
digesting in instant oatmeal well what's
happening at the brain at this time so
in a second study we looked at twelve
another study with twelve overweight and
obese individuals this was a
double-blind study hard to do in
nutrition we gave them milkshakes that
had the same protein fat and
carbohydrate one was fast-acting
carbohydrates as digesting high glycemic
index the other slow digesting
the taste of the meals was controlled so
that people couldn't tell one as more
sweeter than the other and as expected
blood sugar rose again higher after the
fast-acting milkshake
then the slow-acting milkshake hunger
increased more rapidly after the
fast-acting milkshake and then
functional magnetic resonance imaging of
the brain comparing these two meals
showed one area lit up very intensely
after the high glycemic rapidly
digesting milkshake the p-value here
even adjusting for multiple comparisons
throughout the brain was very strong
this area is called the nucleus
accumbens it's considered the center
it's the center of the striatal
dopaminergic reward system and it's
considered ground zero for the classic
addictions cocaine heroin smoking
alcoholism raising the possibility that
some of the highly processed
carbohydrates in their diets may be
hijacking these fund these primordial
pleasure pathways producing in effect
food addiction so in the last study I'll
describe we took we looked at tried to
look at this phenomenon over a little
longer of time period we took 21 obese
young adults who had been weight stable
gave them everything they ate for a
seven-month period first brought their
weight down by 10 to 15% that places
stress on their physiology and then
studied them for one month at a time on
either a conventional low-fat
high-carbohydrate diet at the other
extreme a very low carbohydrate Atkins
type diet and in the middle sort of a
low glycemic index Mediterranean type
diet and here's what we saw after weight
loss when the subjects remember this was
a crossover study when the subjects were
on the low-fat diet their metabolic rate
dropped by 400 calories a day
huge plummet more than could be expected
by the weight loss on the low-carb diet
no statistically significant decline in
energy expenditure at all this
difference and the low glycemic index
diet in the middle showed an
intermediate result this difference of
325 calories
des is the whole obesity epidemic if
that were persistent that difference if
allowed to extrapolate would amount to
about 25 to 30 pounds
so in summary and I think I'll remain on
time
I think I'll just sit here for 30
seconds and enjoy the cyber the
conventional approach to weight loss the
calorie restricted diet has poor
efficacy an environment with unlimited
calorie availability an alternative
approach aims to reduce the anabolic
drive leading to reduced adiposity with
ad libitum conditions free feeding
reduced anabolic Drive may be achieved
by lowering total carbohydrates or the
processing of the carbohydrates and
other qualitative changes in our diet
and our lifestyle that we didn't have
time to talk about and future research
really needs to compare strategies
conventional static strategies which is
focused on just forcing calories down
versus strategies that improve dietary
quality and allow the body to control
its weight more effectively